I start if everyone could just turn
their cell phones off
alright I think we'll begin welcome to
the National Press Club I'm Margaret
angle i'm the managing editor of the
newseum the museum of news which is
going to reopen on Pennsylvania Avenue
this fall and we're here to talk about
Watergate and could Watergate happen
today and in what form and I'm joined by
a very distinguished panel of
investigative reporters and producers
and book authors and we're going to
start by introducing left to right Lisa
Sheppard Alisa Shepherd is the author of
a new book on Woodward and Bernstein
called Woodward and Bernstein life in
the shadow of Watergate that John Wiley
& Sons just published next to lisa is
Jack Nelson who covered Watergate for
the Los Angeles Times and has been at
the forefront of many investigative
pieces throughout his long career in
journalism both in this deep south in
here in Washington and his most recent
book is terror in the night the clans
campaign against the Jews to my right
mike is a cough who is a investigative
reporter with Newsweek he also has a new
book called hubris the inside story of
spin scandal and the selling of the Iraq
war and he wrote it with david corn who
is the Washington editor of the nation
and that's just been published by Crown
and to his right is Rhonda Schwartz
who's an investigative producer with ABC
News with Brian Ross and they broke the
mark foley story which had a huge impact
on this year's mid-year elections so we
are going to start first with Alicia
talking about her book and a bit about
why Watergate was so such a watershed
for our business and fast-forward what
if it happened today okay well I will
begin by reminding you all of what it
was like in 1972 the media climate was
completely different than anything we
know today there were three television
stations newspapers really played a very
prominent role in every day
society during Watergate people actually
ran out to their doors to their curb to
get the newspaper to find out what had
happened that day the washington post
was an up-and-coming newspaper it was
definitely not the paper that it is
today the attitude between the White
House press corps and the White House
was quite different than anything we
know today it was much more deferential
and much more gentlemanly so a lot is
different today and I have to remind I'm
a professor at American University i
have to remind students and re-educate
them about what it was like during those
days and into that scene came these two
young reporters everybody remembers Bob
Woodward and Carl Bernstein who Bob
Woodward had only been at the post for
nine months when the break-in occurred
on jun 17 1972 and Carl Bernstein had
been there about six years and was not
that well thought of at the time and at
the time that they started reporting
they really did not like each other and
what surprises many people is today they
are friends I could go on and on and
remind you of all the things that happen
during Watergate but for the influence
that it had on politics and the
presidency and journalism was tremendous
and I my specialty as journalism so I'll
just remind you that there was a
tremendous interest in going into
journalism among many of my peers here
right after Watergate the there was a
rise of investigative reporting there
certainly there have been investigative
reporting before Watergate but there was
a real it became a staple in newsrooms
the relationship between the White House
press corps and the White House became
very adversarial it was also the
beginning of celebrity journalists in
many ways Bob Woodward and Carl
Bernstein are the first celebrity
journalists certainly there were
journalists before that who were famous
but they became celebrities because of
the fame that they achieved and also
because they became the story so I just
throw that out too
remind you of just what the influence
was on the press corps today and how
journalism has changed thank you and Jay
Nelson because you were covering this
story then and you've been writing and
reporting ever since that time can you
contrast for us a bit about what it was
like to cover that big story such a
watershed and then go on to big stories
since then well one thing about it was
that every morning if you were a
reporter in Washington every morning
when you woke up you had to run out and
grab the paper first thing just to see
what had happened or you know turn on
the news it was it was an unbelievable
time and I think every reporter who
covered it I was excited about it there
were three of us in the LA Times
Washington bureau Ron Ostrow who's here
bob jackson and myself and and i
actually was working on another story
when it when it happened and was working
on another book I was working on you
whether you ever heard of the FBI on the
berrigan's but I was I was working on a
book with Ron ostrow and as a matter of
fact the National editor of the paper
who was quite concerned because he
wanted me to spend more time on
Watergate which I probably should have
done but but I didn't for a long time
but it was a it was one of the most
exciting times that I've seen in in 50
years of journalism every day there was
something new and we were all concerned
about the fact that the Post said seem
to have the inside track on the story
just about all the time but uh they did
I wanted to add something that I the
good fortune or not to have gone back
and read a lot of the stories that were
written by woodward and bernstein in the
early you know from june seventeenth
1972 until the end of 7 d the end of the
years 1972 and i think the people
romanticize the watergate in some ways
because those stars were hard to read
they certainly did not have the polish
that journalistic stories have today and
they were hard to follow and it wasn't
really until the book appeared in 1974
that book being
the President's Men that the whole story
was put together in a way that people
could really understand it well those
kind of incremental stories are still
happening in major investigative pieces
in fact the one that I'm thinking of is
from the Toledo Blade that is called
coin gate and of course this is
Watergate everything since then has had
the word gate added to it but Ron Roy
have the editor totaled up recently the
fact that they had done six hundred
stories on coin gate in Ohio and had to
move all their reporters who are working
on it into Columbus to look at the
tedious number of boxes and records that
were finally given up by the state
authorities about this scandal so I
think that's sort of a direct descendant
of Watergate but Mike I want to ask you
you've done a lot of shoe leather
reporting on many important stories in
this city and how has Watergate informed
or effect of those well I I mean in the
shadow of Watergate I think the title of
Lisa's book is you know has taken many
forms and affected all of us and
probably while it clearly inspired an
entire generation of investigative
reporters of which I am one and
therefore got a lot of people interested
in doing the kind of work that Woodward
and Bernstein did it's probably also had
a somewhat deleterious effect and in the
sense that everybody in when when big
stories come along look for the crime
the the the the violation of the
criminal statute that validates the
scandal and it becomes necessary to find
that somebody is that somebody committed
a crime of felony that they're going to
go to jail for and relatives about
firemen hiding an arsonist but as a
result I think we we in the press
sometimes miss what is the more
significant story and I'm thinking in
the context of the book I just wrote
with David corn which the the subtitle
is the inside story of spin scandal and
the selling of the Iraq war there was a
whole lot of attention in finding the
violation of the criminal statute in the
leaking of Valerie Plame's identity an
enormous amount of investigative
resources we all devoted to reporting
that out you know we and you Burris
actually disclosed the original source
for that it turned out to be surprised
surprised Richard Armitage not a member
of the White House staff not a not
somebody who was trying to defend the
original sales pitch of the White House
but actually it was just gossiping first
a Woodward and then to Bob Novak but you
know as a result I think it kind of
diverted us from what was the real story
which is the last part of our subtitle
the selling of the Iraq war which is a
political scandal that Dwarfs any
possible violation of criminal law that
was out there in the plane gate scandal
but I think is going to have historical
resonance as one of the great political
scandals of our era rivaling Watergate
in many ways after all at the end of the
day the United States launched in a
military invasion of another country on
what has it turned out to be entirely
false and in many cases fraudulent
pretenses a false reality was presented
to the American public in virtually
every respect and all this took place in
plain sight in the in the in the fall of
two thousand two in the winter of 2003
and I think the the contribution we've
really made in you Burris is to
demonstrate that there were a whole lot
of people inside the government who knew
what was being said publicly was wrong
that there were dissents the
there were doubts that they were written
down in memos and emails and we in the
press by and large missed it some in the
press were a lot better than others some
got pieces of the story others in the
press were cheerleaders for the fraud
that was being perpetrated and I use
that word I don't mean to suggest that
there were deliberate lies but there
certainly were as I think we've
demonstrated embellishments twisting of
intelligence grossly exaggerated
statements when when if you look at the
record and you look what was being said
inside the government at the time there
was ample reason to doubt what was being
said and what we didn't do which is get
at those people who were out there who
were available to be interviewed it
would have taken a hell of a lot of
coaxing it would have taken the kind of
door knocking that would ruin Bernstein
did for the people who worked at creep
to knock on the doors of the people who
were the energy department scientists
who knew that the aluminum tubes story
was a fraud the aluminum tube story was
the basis for we can't wait for the
smoking gun in the form of the mushroom
cloud you know the most vivid and scary
metaphor that was being used by the
White House knocking on the doors of the
people inside the CIA knew the al Qaeda
connection was just not supported by the
evidence that was the kind of aggressive
press that was needed just a few years
ago and it was I think you know the a
political scandal that rivals Watergate
jumping off on your idea of how the
press really needed to be knocking on
doors Rhonda well I was interested so
much that your story really has a whole
new dimension that brings it into this
generation where it was truly opening
the door to the people via the email and
web so could you explain a bit about how
of you were sort of knocking on virtual
doors that's a good way to put it i
don't i don't have a
book to plug but i do have a website to
plug my creation this year a new twist
in the tale of investigative reporting
is for the first time we have a daily
investigative reporting website at ABC
News and despite its it's been widely
quoted as a blog and we've had a little
fun with the name we call it not a blog
but the blotter because indeed we're not
blogging we are putting out daily news
stories investigative stories with the
same standards and vetting that any
other report we put on ABC News goes
through but it enables us as the we have
a very we have an investigative team of
11 people at ABC News and a lot of them
are just like Woodward and Bernstein I
had to laugh Ali snooze book is a
wonderful depiction of the life of the
reporter and the throes of the big story
and she wrote at one point when they're
at the peak they didn't eat they didn't
sleep and they had no life I hear that
every day from the people who work for
us particularly when Woodward actually
said I don't have any soap I can't wash
my hair and so the city editor at the
time sent a copy person out to buy him
soap well if necessary we tell him to
buy the underwear and you know put it on
the expense account is it taxi the but
essentially I it's also as she describes
these were two reporters who were not
the beat reporters they came in on a
Sunday and they started with a very
potentially small story and essentially
in the case of the mark foley a scandal
that we just recently broke the story of
it started very much the same way we had
what we thought was a very good story
maybe not a huge story but a very solid
very good story which we were able to
confirm that mark foley that there had
been complaints from a page about his
inappropriate overtures to him over the
Internet we had full reporting a good
response from his office who discussed
the whole situation with us at length
and it was at that stage we thought
blotter worthy and so the story went out
over our blotter it was a print story it
was not a front-page you know wasn't a
headline on the evening news but we have
on our page we have an anonymous tip
line people can send us tips videos
whatever they want to send in and very
quickly we heard from several other
sources who had information about a
number of other young men who had
received very explicit emails from Mark
Foley and within 24 hours really we were
able to make use of these tips that came
in vet the sources examined material and
go back to mark Foley's office and
confront them with the new information
now here's where one thing was quite
different in the new cyberspace
reporting compared to Watergate is
opposed to waiting how many years for
resignation we made that phone call on
friday morning and by 2 30 we had
received a phone call that mark foley
was resigning was it was much different
time frame uh then of course it
continued very much in the Watergate
mode it really became a question of the
cover-up more than the original incident
and as you know it then became an issue
of very quickly who knew what when and a
great deal of finger-pointing ensued
around this town which still is yet a
story which we have not written the
ending to though we certainly are
planning to do the best we can what's so
clear is that Ron to talk about the very
shortened time frame now that you get
her resignation hours after the story
breaks but at the time we were really in
the incremental stage in Watergate do
you think that has anything to do with
the fact that we were really considered
more heroes back in the time of
Watergate and now where I think fairly
uniformly seen as as villains that
journalism has taken a real hit and is
it because of this pack mentality the
feeling that there is an attack in the
air and you have to really resign first
and
ask questions later well I think there's
probably something to that but I'm not
so sure that we weren't any attack mode
during Watergate as well certainly would
wouldn't burn Singler and and so is the
LA Times for that matter time magazine
and some other publications got into the
attack mode I mean it took a while but
but but they did one of the big
differences I see now is that if you do
since you have the internet and and you
have all of the bloggers out there if
you have a big scandal now I mean it's
all over the place right away I mean you
know it's not just coming out in the
post in the morning or in the LA Times
or in the New York Times it's all over
them and so I think it would be very
difficult to have a scandal of that size
that would go on for month after month
after month I think it would come to a
head a whole lot quicker simply because
the the distribution of the information
would be so rapid throughout the country
and you would have so many people not
just the other newspapers with
television but all of the bloggers would
be on the case too I'd like to explore
that notion of of sort of our decline
and why don't people love us anymore you
know though we once were the heroes and
now we certainly are I don't think that
when they were at least Woodward and
Bernstein were not heroes at the time
and again I can't emphasize enough the
influence of having a movie made about
you where Robert Redford Flay's you and
Dustin Hoffman also plays you have the
book All the President's Men came out in
june of 1974 before we even knew what
the outcome was and then in night april
of nineteen seventy-six the movie came
out and that's when Woodward and
Bernstein really became heroes it's
interesting to recall that the when they
the book all the president's men came
out as a paperback and in 1976 Dustin
Hoffman and Robert Redford were on the
cover not Woodward and Bernstein and so
the idea of Woodward and Bernstein as
heroes was just really not the case and
I like to tell the story of Jack
is in my book and Ron Austro as well in
terms of what good reporting they did
did they get as much credit no and why
not because they didn't write a book
about it and also Jack was 10 years
older and had before didn't and that was
something that was significant sum of
Watergate seems so much serendipity
Woodward was divorced Bernstein was
separated they wanted nothing to do with
women they wanted to work on this story
and I also don't think they were in an
attack mode either I think they were
just really curious and wanted to get at
what was really going on do you agree
with that I know I do agree with that
and and I think that you talked about
the the attack mode that that's one
reason today that the public is so sets
him down on the press is because there's
so many reporters only attack mode I
mean you head up a team of what eight
investigative reporters you didn't have
any investigative reporters in those
days none of the television networks had
any investigative reports we have won in
the Washington bureau of the LA Times
now I think they're eight at the time I
was investigating reported in the bureau
I was the sole investigative reporter
full-time r on Austro covered the
Justice Department and was an
investigative report although I guess
maybe bob jackson was an investigative
reporter too but but basically there
were very few investigative reporters
and we weren't constantly in the attack
mode today you've got all the networks
with their investigative teams you've
got the news magazines with
investigative teams all of the
newspapers have investigative teams and
we've churning out investigative stories
all the time and it makes people mad as
hell but I think Mike would say at least
with what his reporting showed that they
were pretty alone on this I mean there
were others who were writing about it
but you thought that there were some
true lapses that the investigative
reporters weren't digging into the
yellowcake the fake documents the fraud
behind the aluminum tubes yeah I mean
look I the I well that is a complex
question but I mean the first of all
there's no question that a lot of
news news organizations led by the new
york times were not just not challenging
administration statements they were
promoting cheerleaders for
administration claims I that were
provided the the groundwork for the
invasion of Iraq I mean there is that
classic moment you know maybe we all a
lot of us forgot it but you know go back
we describe it in the book of sep tember
eighth two thousand two this is the week
that the administration is going to
launch what Andy card said at the time
was its sales product you know you don't
launch a sales product before a labor
day you don't do it in August you launch
it right after Labor Day the sales
product was the selling of the war why
we have to go to war to overthrow Saddam
because of the threat of his weapons of
mass destruction and that Sunday the New
York Times runs a front-page story lead
story in the paper Saddam pursuing a
bomb project based on the aluminum tube
claim these tubes that were seized
headed for the Iraqi regime every
scientist in the energy department every
nuclear scientist every expert in the
government on the subject said not true
wrote it down said this isn't the case
but front-page story Michael Gordon Judy
Miller said this was the case the
administration has dramatic new evidence
this is when the mushroom cloud metaphor
is actually even leaked to the times for
this story a national security official
said we can't wait for the smoking gun
in the form of the mushroom cloud MN
Dick Cheney appears voila on Meet the
Press that morning and says we have new
evidence that Iraq is rebuilding its
nuclear program what's the evidence mr.
vice president's asked Tim Russert we
can't well I can't talk
out that of course it's classified but
you might want to look at the front page
of the New York Times and there's Dick
Cheney citing the New York Times as
evidence for what became the most
dramatic and false claim made by the
administration in the selling of the war
was the rest of the press I mean that's
something that I looked at all so where
was the rest rest during Watergate why
weren't they doing their job right well
you know look I mean there was the press
actually doing the opposite of you know
not getting to and then as we described
in the book there's a whole sort of you
know a series of events that play out
where people try to bring to the
attention of the times know you've got
it wrong there are these scientists out
there who say this isn't the case that's
not true and the times of course doesn't
want to then undermine its own
front-page story so they play down the
dissents so I've one of the people who
was playing broker David Albright who's
a former weapons inspector who runs a
think tank in Washington who was in
touch with some of the dissenters then
takes it to the the sentence notifies
the Washington Post and The Washington
Post reporter tries to write about this
and you know what the attitude of his
editors are I you just got scooped by
the times you know they don't really
want to play up the a story that's
contradicting the times and so they're
the very first story suggesting there
was doubt and dissent within the
government gets played on like a 14 or
17 inside the paper never gets any
traction let's talk about that pack
mentality I mean Rhonda know you often
when you've got a story going out you
hear from your affiliated stations of is
there ever a feeling that if it's not
universally declared a truth then you
have trouble selling the story I mean
how Watergate taught us that there were
two brave reporters and a great
publisher who was out there with with
unpleasant news and they managed to keep
at it what's that tenor like
particularly in television today
well I think that you know it's it's
while as jack says there's been a
proliferation of perhaps you know
television stations saying they've got
an i-team and they're doing
investigative reporting in fact I think
there really is only a handful today of
serious investigative reporters and I
may have a large team but we do put
things on every single show that ABC
News does and we've fought very hard to
build up the resources ABC's very
committed to this but it is a there is
still the classic separation it used to
be just jack and then the beat reporters
it's us and then everybody is covering
their beat they're covering they have to
keep an eye on their access will they
get let back into the White House one of
the differences in the Watergate era is
you may recall the description of Ron
Ziegler apologizing to the Washington
Post on one occasion we don't ever get
apologies we get threats and very
serious ones I have been under
investigation when we did a story that a
very time-consuming in-depth
investigation of container port security
we did a demonstration where we took
some depleted uranium and we literally
carried it around the world in container
ships we shipped it to see if he could
get through customs undetected and when
we went to tell US Customs what we had
learned about the holes in the system
their response was to open a grand jury
investigation oh there were later we
were there was in a GAO investigation
that said that customs had lied to
congress in the public about the ABC
news story and indeed it was as we had
reported believe me there were no
apologies no public apologies it was a
very interesting story in The New York
Times business section this week about
subpoenas against reporters and there
was a very interesting the general
counsel of Hearst Corporation said that
in the last year and a half they have
received 80 subpoenas for their
reporters compared with maybe three or
four in the previous time period that is
a hard fact and I think investigative
reporters today are facing a chilling
effect more than ever before it's not a
free and easy
time we have often been out on the limb
many many times and we have to be we are
very very careful in our reporting and
ABC News has been we have serious
standards and we meet them and they back
us up but I don't think you know the
famous so-called mistake that Woodward
and Bernstein made and they survived and
the series they continue to report and
ultimately apology from the White House
I don't think that would happen in
today's environment at all and I don't
think and I think what Mike is talking
about is there are very difficult
stories that take a lot of legwork and
we mean the Foley story that I recounted
to you sounds like pretty easy 24 hours
you have a big story not quite that
simple and frankly the even larger story
as i said the cover-up yet to come as
something we're still digging on that
doesn't come overnight and I mean these
books really lay out the details and the
it often takes we have spent two years
on investigations and it's sometimes you
just have to stay on these things I
literally today I'm just working on
something I've worked on ten years ago I
won't say what it is but its back and
I'm digging back in can I just say one
one thing about the subpoenas in the
environment that's certainly true it
makes it very difficult at times but I
have to say and you know I think Rhonda
and the team at ABC is proof positive
that it it doesn't really intimidate us
I mean you do not stop one second
because of these kind of threats and and
these kind of subpoenas and yes it can
make it difficult at times but you're
still doing you know a groundbreaking
reporting and a lot of other people are
and in spite of it all you know we forge
ahead and sources still talk yes well
funded news organizations here and for
those of us who started out in the
hinterlands we know that those
publishers are facing true true
financial fears and that the hostility
towards the press is playing out in a
very dangerous and scary way daily
I know we want to take some questions
here so yes go ahead my reaction was
very different from my friends my
reaction was the Watergate happened
tonight and forget it because because
everybody talked about the internet fast
disc and information but you didn't have
then the Department of Defense trying to
control free flow of information you
didn't have the vice president's office
doing what it does now and I i really
think that in a way now we have so much
and then your story particularly the
Iraq story the Defense Department got so
involved and and we still have rugs film
to take into next year react to respond
your era I'd like Captain respond
because in your era I don't think the OD
and I don't think my definitely in the
vice president's office we're very
involved in the free flow of information
nothing they're very concerned that the
reason I'm asking Jack to do this is
that you faced all sorts of pressures
from state local federal all the way up
oh yeah I don't think that that's
anything new at all I must say and it
certainly happened during the Watergate
investigations I mean you had you had
young the Justice Department was doing
what it could to cover up things I don't
see the distinction I think some of the
interesting things that happened to
Woodward and Bernstein was as many of
you know Oh Carl's parents had been
members of the Communist Party and so he
was worried right from the start that
the Nixon administration would use that
against him and yet that never happened
but he went right away to Ben Bradlee
and told them about that and Ben Bradley
was also concerned that the post was
being bugged and did a sweep of the
newsroom he told them not to smoke pot
not to go
certain parties so there was a concern
and there was no doubt that the Nixon
administration was very vindictive they
did attempt in the end of December 1972
to hurt the posts by challenging their
licenses and to TV 42 TV stations in
Florida the stock price of the post
dropped from thirty-eight dollars to 21
dollars in the beginning of 1973 and yet
they post stuck with that story and I
think we largely to the support and
credit and courage of katherine graham
and Woodward and Bernstein are very well
aware i read many articles that were
written at the time where people ask
them and tried to portray them as heroes
and yet they would say if the post
hadn't backed them they might as well
have been writing letters home to their
parents that that was very important and
that's really what i see a certain
erosion of today is that newspaper
companies television station owners are
not always willing to back the reporters
all the way sometimes it's just easier
to let a story go and i think that that
is one of the highlights and best parts
of Watergate was that the post stuck
with a very scary story yes in today's
climate with
advertisers and audience having so many
choices beyond the mainstream media and
wondering if you think that coverage of
the Iraq war was in way diminish because
the media was doing what we often was
accusing politicians are doing reading
their own poll attic no public does not
trust the media it has decreasing
interest in the media and what do you
think there was too much fear that the
audience would turn on the if you
reported this good question power of
advertisers I think there was um a
climate of fear in the country as a
result of September 11th remember the
vote on congressional resolution to
authorize war against Iraq is is the the
the White House begins its campaign on
the very week of the first anniversary
of 911 memories were vivid of it and the
administration played on the you know
legitimate fears of the American public
about a terrorist attack to push a war
that really had virtually nothing to do
with the terrorist attack of September
11th but that was um if there was any
single factor that influences the
emotional mood of the country and
therefore the emotional mood of the
press it was I think it was that and
there was an element of cynical
manipulation there there's no question
the White House wanted the vote before
the November election they wanted to use
it we quote a White House official in
hubris talking about wanting to use the
the anvil of the election to hammer the
Democrats to force them to support the
president before the election to put it
to them and make them choose before sort
of daring them to vote against the
president going into a election where
they could be hammered for being soft on
national security and it worked to the
max
in you know look at the votes of Senate
Democrats particularly everyone who had
harboured presidential ambitions every
single Democrat who harbored
presidential ambitions supported the
president on the vote on Iraq yes I used
to work with Jack at the LA Times I've
got to operation a question on
operational tools and techniques as all
of you and everyone in the audience is
old enough to have worked in two eras
pre enter internet now how would you
compare the tips that people used to get
over the phone and by letters with the
tips that people get by email now are
there are they more are they better does
it make the job easier or is the ratio
of good stuff to trash the same I would
have to say to ratio is still the same I
can tell you firsthand for the five good
tips there is a thousand that you got
away through and I learned this when we
first started the website I was actually
some people said to me oh don't put a
tip line there you're really going to
regret it obviously we don't regret
doing it but I have had the experience
where some very good tips came in and I
immediately wrote back and said Oh call
me right away on my cell phone only to
find my cell phone ringing off the hook
until one nice person said to me do you
know that your cell phones been posted
on the internet and telling people to
call you so but you know we all got I i
started often you know when it was still
an eighth book and typewriter and we all
used to get those letters that were
single spaced written in pencil on
yellow paper and they'd be a thick
envelope and it might say from you know
prisoner XO you've my cases we're going
to bring down the the government we all
got those i think it's it's similar it's
just there's there's a little higher
volume but one of the reasons why i
wrote this book as many of you may know
that Woodward and Bernstein sold their
papers to the University of Texas 45
million dollars and this is about 75
boxes that cover about thirty one and a
half feet of shelf space and what I
found fascinating in there is there
about almost three feet of
headers and most of them were fan
letters but many of them were these
letters that people thought wow if you
can bring down a president which is of
course a myth that they did that but
then I think you better help me with
investigating fluoride haunted houses
the military I think my favorite was
mrs. chronixx missing husband in Cuba
but and they were all that same single
spaced you know typed letter call me
right away and so things haven't changed
at all but the fan letters would just
really show you and remind you of what
heavy times those were and how young
they were not many people in here look
like they're 29 but by the time Bob
Woodward and Carl Bernstein were 30
years old there were household names
they were wealthy beyond most of our
wildest dreams what we hope to achieve
in a lifetime by the end of 1974 the
royalties from All the President's Men
amounted to about six hundred thousand
dollars had Bob Woodward not written a
book had Carl not written a book Bob
would have earned eighteen thousand
dollars and Carl would I'm sorry Bob
would have earned 15,000 and Carl 18,000
and so you really get a sense I mean
many of you may remember just how they
became like heroes folk heroes at the
time would you say that was true Jeff oh
yeah absolutely no question about it
there's a question here
what's kind of my factors
could you repeat the question the
question was what factors are going to
bring back integrity a higher form of
integrity for investigative journalism
I'll just say one thing that Carnegie
Foundation has been very concerned about
this issue and they started an
initiative two years ago to try to get
journalism students to have real-world
education investigative reporting and
they basically hand-picked some graduate
students and sent us them for the summer
and we've started this on a regular
basis so every summer now I have a
hands-on investigative reporting
workshop at ABC News we've hired a lot
of the graduates we've tried to instill
all the values that we think they should
have that's a slow process but maybe
we'll have some impact that's one thing
that we've been doing at our end
investigative reporters and editors a
group that's been going for almost 30
years now 30 or 12 no I 30-dec we came
out of Watergate that was founded in
nineteen seventy five and that I saw I
mean that wasn't just the reason but it
rang off then but it has short courses
in annual courses and all devoted to the
effort that reporters have integrity and
there are standards and there are
methods and doing it right and a very
serious group of journalists about 3,500
journalists both TV radio print and so I
think those of us on this side of the
table who judge journalism contests are
perhaps more amazed every year at the
very high quality ethical journalism
that goes on that doesn't get the klieg
lights and the attention but that may
not win the golden prize of the Pulitzer
but are out there doing important things
and that always surprises me that it
really these stories fall beneath the
radar screen and that they don't get the
attention that they deserve often
because their regional but I'm certain
that there are really important reasons
to raise the ethical standards but on
the other side I think that there's so
much good journalism going out there
that's unremarked on and
and not really seen I think the use of
anonymous sources is something that we
might discuss and that certainly was a
legacy of Watergate and if I were to ask
you all who is the most famous anonymous
source in American history everyone
would say deep throat and of course he
was a literary device and a character
that appeared in their book he certainly
didn't appear in the Washington Post but
that really was something that came out
of Watergate was the popularization and
almost it was glamorous to use anonymous
sources I interviewed a TV reporter who
had been I think worked at NBC in
1976-77 and he told me about coming back
to the station and he had gotten a guy
on the record and the producer was
downtrodden you know what is not an
anonymous source and so I think that
that is a sad commentary and yet I I
guess I'd lie ask rhonda and jack and
mike about the use of anonymous sources
i mean Woodward is very clear he thinks
you get better information if you have
an anonymous source I would disagree I
think it's better to get people on the
record what word would tell you will
they lie on the record but then you have
them on the record line so what do you
all think about the history in fluency
of anonymous sources and I'll tell us
about the first time someone said this
was on deep background right on the most
routine ordinary you know what time is
the meeting right question yeah well i
think the use of anonymous sources is
really important and investigative i
don't think there's any question about
that but i think they can be overused
and i and i think that when you have a
book that says that we have 394
anonymous sources that's asking a little
bit too much of the reader I mean you
you're writing an omniscient book and
and Jack is referring to the book the
final days right came out in nineteen
april of nineteen seventy six within a
week of the movie All the President's
Men coming out and and I think little
dude with what 394 yes 394 anonymous
sources i mean that's asking i think a
little bit too much of the
but i do think anonymous sources are
important because there are often people
in particularly in government who want
to help because they want to help you
because they really want the truth to
come out about something wrong doing
within government but obviously they
don't want to lose their job and so you
know they'll talk in and say well I can
tell you this but you cannot quote me
and I think it's perfectly all right but
I think if you use them you need to do
it with some discretion and you need to
to wherever you can get sources on the
record as well particularly to back up
what somebody said on the background
basis yeah there's definitely a role for
them in journalism and they play a key
role but they need to be used more
judiciously Mike have you found it
harder to get people to go on the record
well it's always on any sensitive story
it is always difficult to get somebody
to go on the record on any story that's
challenging the official position of the
administration or the government anybody
who speaks on the record questioning
that is putting their own jobs and
livelihood I at risk so of course I to
get at the truth you need to use
anonymous sources they are essential to
investigative journalism you can't do it
without it that said I agree with Jack
that getting people on the record also
often at the end of the day you got to
work hard to do it but it gives the
story the level of credibility that it
might not otherwise have when it's based
on anonymous sources just one brief
example from from you Burris that you
know probably the thing that got the
most made the most news from the book
was that Armitage was the source for
Novak an anonymous source as it were we
had plenty of anonymous sources telling
us that we knew it to be true but until
we got one of Armitage 'as top
associates on the record saying yes he
told me it was him he did it he felt
terrible about it blah blah blah but he
was the guy you know that was the
that was the key element that allowed us
to sort of you know get the credit for
breaking the story what a story that a
lot of people knew anonymously but
nobody was could really go out on a limb
until you had the on the record source
Rhonda what do you find well i would i
would certainly second everything that
Mike and Jack just said and I mean in
television we have it's sort of
reporting cubed we we can get the basic
story and use those techniques and and
we do use anonymous sources as needed
because as Mike said for the very
important stories often you need to do
that then we have a unique problem if we
want to bring the story to you people
will often say to me well I'll talk but
you got to put me in the shadows you got
to disguise me and you know I often say
well that's like being a little bit
pregnant and how do you expect people to
really believe you that your courage of
your convictions only one so far and as
a rule we do not put anybody on
television in the shadows because I
think that is that's sort of a cop-out I
do a plot there's a very interesting
anecdote in Lisa's book about Jack
pushing the key interview and Watergate
to go on the record and how dogged you
were to get that interview maybe you
could tell that story but I think that's
a real lesson that's what I think we
strive to do that as journalist is to
really hold people's feet to the fire
whenever possible okay you'll be on
background or you'll be anonymous and
let people do that but yes tell that
story it's great about Al Baldwin well
al Baldwin was the former FBI agent who
worked with a committee for election of
the president and stayed over in a
howard johnson hotel across from
Watergate and listened in on the taped
conversations of the Democratic National
Committee and everybody had been trying
to get is he lived up in Connecticut and
everybody had been trying to get his
story and his lawyers were actually
interested in selling his story and and
I went up and talked to him and stayed
after him and I said well number one
nobody's going to buy the story and if
they did it wouldn't be worth it if you
if you're going to sell the story but I
said look let me I said let me sit down
with bowling and get his first person
story it'll be just as he tells it and
there's you
getting everybody everybody else will be
out of your hair then only other
reporters won't be after you and so he
did they sat down and I sat down for
several hours and tape-recorded albo and
he gave his first person story of how he
worked with the committee for the
re-election of the president so forth
and uh and who did you know it worked
out he have one concern Denis about how
he was being portrayed well he did yes
he he was he was he said he who is his
girlfriend would probably read this
story since he was on the record and he
said you know I'm a marine he said he
was a little pudgy actually he said
would you mind referring to me as a
husky ex-marine did you so I did I call
him a husky experiment on him he was
budget it was an honest characterization
I have one other thought that uh I've
developed in the book which is and it's
something to think about today one of
the main reasons why Nixon resigned was
not really because of Woodward and
Bernstein's reporting because actually
reporters can only do so much they can
shine a spotlight on something they
don't have the power to subpoena or hold
grand juries or force people to testify
so that that's what the Woodward and
Bernstein did and Jack and Ron at the LA
Times and other people but it was
actually the fact that they we had a
Republican president who was and had a
house and senate that were controlled by
the democrats and if it hadn't been for
the senate watergate hearings nixon
never would have resigned and so i often
wonder what would it have been like if
we when bush decided to go to war if
there had been a democratically
controlled senate or a democratically
controlled house and i think that you
have the answer that's a very good
question although actually the democrats
did control the senate up until the
november two thousand two elections but
you're absolutely right the
institutional checks of the american
government is what brought richard nixon
down the Senate you know holding the
watergate hearings the house holding the
impeachment hearings but at the end of
the day it was the courts I mean it was
the it was a judge sarika
then the Supreme Court ordering that the
tapes be turned over like we would never
know about the tapes if the Senate
hadn't held the Watergate hearings
anyway I just remind you that the
hearings went from may of 73 to 19 to
August of 1973 237 hours and the average
American family watched 30 hours of them
many of you remember watching that it's
just to continue the chicken and egg
game here but with the urban committee
hearings have taken place if it wasn't
for judge sarika in March of 73 ordering
saying I'm not accepting this story that
these guys these burglars are telling me
those hearings so everything did there
were many factors and I think that's
important because out doing the research
for my book how I can't tell you how
many times i stumbledupon reporters
writing about Woodward and Bernstein as
the two reporters who brought down a
president they did not bring down a
president they played a role in Nixon's
demise first of all Nixon was a crook
and Nixon played the biggest role but
without those hearings and actually I
think one of the I won't call him a hero
but one of the linchpins was Alexander
Butterfield Nixon's aide who revealed to
the Senate Watergate hearings that there
were tapes in fact at the time only
about four people knew that there were
tapes and can you tell us what Alexander
Butterfield said to you a few weeks ago
when he came up to you at your book
signing at politics and prose he told me
I was pretty historical moment right now
that one is one last question has to go
full bore on a story like Iraq when the
opposition that is to say the Democratic
Party was so supine at the time I mean
can the press to sort of take off in a
vacuum when there's no political well
that's a very good question and it
certainly helps to have you know the
opposition party out there Fanning the
flames but let's cut back to Watergate
when Woodward and Bernstein were you
know doing the real on the ground shoe
leather reporting in in Watergate I
don't think the Democrats were making a
major issue of this this was during the
72 campaign it wasn't front-page news it
wasn't being a fan the flames I guess
they did file a civil suit early on on
the burglary and that that did play
somewhat of a role but basically they
were out there one in 1972 with all but
one state Massachusetts was the only
state that did not go for Nixon so and
plus the majority of the newspapers at
that time endorsed Nixon so I don't know
if you would call that a climate of fear
but it was certainly not a climate where
other reporters had the support of their
newspapers in fact this was of course
before the internet and so the post was
doing a lot of reporting the new york
times but it wasn't getting out there
the gallup poll in nineteen in november
of 1972 said only forty-eight percent of
the country had ever even heard the word
Watergate well i hope then we can all
endorser the lone wolf version of
reporters being very necessary and that
the Fourth Estate really won't succeed
if we don't have these independent
actors working for the Fourth Estate I
want to remind everyone that we have for
sale out in the lobby both Alicia's book
and Mike's book on hubris and we welcome
the fact that you were here and thank
you for your good questions we
appreciate you being here thanks